une minute de silence en mémoire
d'idriss deby réunis à luanda pour un
sommet politique
plusieurs chefs d'état du continent
africain salue la mémoire de leurs
homologues décéder quelques heures
auparavant un hommage suivi d'une prise
de parole du chef de la diplomatie
angolaise
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement ont
exprimé leurs sentiments de profonde
tristesse suite au décès de son
excellence le maréchal idriss deby itno
président de la république du tchad
survenu aujourd'hui dans son pays et ont
présenté leurs condoléances au
gouvernement et au peuple tchadien
ainsi qu'à la famille biologique la
famille les a tour à tour plusieurs
dirigeants africains ont twitté pour
exprimer leurs sentiments
j'ai appris avec consternation la mort
tragique d'idriss deby itno président en
exercice du g5 sel
je salue la mémoire d'un frère d'un
grand panafricaniste engagé avec
conviction et détermination dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme dans le
bassin du lac tchad et au sahel
le président idriss deby itno est mort
comme il a vécu en combattant mes
condoléances les plus attristées à sa
famille et au peuple tchadien dans cette
épreuve douloureuse le chat pourra
compter sur la solidarité du gabon la
disparition du maréchal idriss deby itno
est une immense perte pour le tchad
l'afrique centrale et notre continent
qu'il aura servie sans relâche
c'est avec une grande émotion que je
viens d'apprendre la mort d'idriss deby
itno président en exercice du g5 sahel
je présente mes condoléances attristées
à sa famille et au peuple tchadien
quel à l'accueil au paradis ailleurs
dans le monde les réactions ont
également été nombreuses washington ou
encore paris ont adressé leurs
condoléances envers le peuple tchadien
au nom des états unis nous présentons au
peuple tchadien nos sincères
condoléances qui fait le deuil du
président deby
nous condamnons les récentes violences
et les pertes de vies humaines au tchad
les etats unis sont aux côtés du peuple
tchadien en cette période difficile
nous soutenons une transition pacifique
du pouvoir en accord avec la
constitution tchadienne
nous avons appris avec émotion la
disparition du président idriss deby est
avant toute chose je voudrais exprimer
mes condoléances au peuple tchadien
mes très sincères condoléances je dois
dire que la france faire un allié
essentiel dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme au sahel au pouvoir depuis 30
ans idriss déby a été tué dans des
combats contre des rebelles
un conseil militaire dirigée par son
fils a pris sa succession à la tête du
tchad pour une transition de 18 mois